S
STORY.
RICH EDSON LIVE AT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT.
RICH, THANKS.
TONIGHT, LAW ENFORCEMENT AROUND
THE COUNTRY INVESTIGATING A
SERIES OF BRUTAL ATTACKS IN
SEVERAL MAJOR AMERICAN CITIES
OVER THE WEEKEND.
DOZENS WERE SHOT, SOME KILLED.
AND MANY ARE BLAMING THE
ANTI-POLICE ATTITUDE THAT COULD
INSPIRE A BACKLASH AT THE POLLS.
CORRESPONDENT AISHAH HASNIE
SHOWS US TONIGHT FROM NEW YORK.
>> SOME VICIOUS ATTACKS IN BROAD
DAYLIGHT TO COLD BLOODED MURDERS
BY NIGHT.
ANOTHER SUMMER OF SIN IS ALREADY
UNDERWAY IN NEW YORK CITY.
SHOOTINGS YEAR-TO-DATE ARE UP
81%.
THIS WEEKEND ALONE, 27 PEOPLE
WERE WOUNDED IN 22 SHOOTINGS.
INCLUDING A MANHATTAN FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR HIT BY A STRAY BULLET
IN THE FACE WHILE HAVING DINNER
AT A RESTAURANT.
BULLS WENT FLYING IN NEW JERSEY
THIS WEEKEND WHERE A BIRTHDAY
PARTY TURNED INTO A MASS
SHOOTING.
14 PARTY GOERS WERE SHOT.
TWO DIED.
COMMUNITY MEMBERS BLAMED GANG
WARS.
CHICAGO HAD A WORSE WEEKEND
WHERE NINE PEOPLE WERE KILLED
AND 38 INJURED BY GUNFIRE.
THE VICTIMS INCLUDE A
15-YEAR-OLD BOY SHOT IN THE HEAD
WHILE SITTING ON A FRONT PORCH.
>> WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO.
>> GUNFIRE IS UP IN SEVERAL
MAJOR CITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
BUT PRESSURE CONTINUES TO MOUNT
ON POLICE.
IN ST. LOUIS, WHICH HAS THE
WORST MURDER RATE IN THE
COUNTRY, DEMOCRATIC MAYOR THAT
SHARIA JONES IS TRYING TO DEFUND
THE POLICE BY $4 MILLION AND
SHUT DOWN A CITY JAIL.
AND NEW YORK'S ATTORNEY GENERAL
LATISHA JAMES NOW PUSHING THE
POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY ACT.
IF PASSED, IT WOULD LIMIT POLICE
OFFICERS' DISCRETION AND THEIR
ABILITY TO USE EXCESSIVE OR
DEADLY FORCE WHILE MAKING IT
EASIER TO PROSECUTE OFFICERS WHO
DO.
AS OFFICIALS RESPOND TO PUBLIC
OUTCRIES FOR CHANGE, "NEW YORK
TIMES" COLUMNIST EZRA KLEIN
WARNS DEMOCRATS ABOUT THE
POLITICAL RAMIFICATIONS OF
SPIKING CRIME.
HE WRITES:  IF THESE NUMBERS
KEEP RISING, THEY COULD END ANY
CHANCE WE HAVE OF BUILDING A NEW
APPROACH TO SAFETY AND POSSIBLY
CARRY DONALD TRUMP OVER SOMEONE
LIKE HIM BACK TO THE PRESIDENCY
IN 2024.
LAW ENFORCEMENT EXPERTS LAYING
DOWN A STARK WARNING OF THEIR
OWN.
>> I SEE SKYROCKETING GUN
VIOLENCE.
I SEE FURTHER DIMINISHED AND
DISEMPOWERED POLICE.
>> AND, BRET, BACK HERE IN NEW
YORK, STATE COURTS HAVE NOW
FULLY REOPENED.
KEEP THIS DATE IN MIND BECAUSE
MAYOR BILL DE BLASIO OF NEW YORK
CITY HAS LONG SAID THAT CRIME
WILL START TO DECLINE AS SOON AS
THE COURTS REOPEN.
SO WE WILL WATCH A